[Musique]
comme eux ils sont nombreux qui sans
être coeliaque veulent manger sans
gluten pour frais de savoir les aliments
qui en contiennent lui apporte plus
d'inconfort que de plaisir via le
brûlement ballonnements l'inflammation
serait pas il se lance alors à la
recherche de pape qui ne contiennent pas
de blé dame avait déjà sur le marché
l'époque y en avait quelques uns
le chef pascual martone à quelqu'un dans
son entourage qui doit manger sans
gluten on les pose qui est intolérable
butelle il a donc développé une recette
qu'il offre aussi à son restaurant
nous on voulait donner la même
expérience aux clients qui étaient sans
gluten ou qu'il n'était pas la
nutritionniste catherine lefebvre
analyse pour nous une trentaine de pâtes
sans gluten de type spaghetti la grande
majorité des parts sont faits à base de
céréales comme le blé le riz brun les
kinois le maïs il y'as est ces nouvelles
parties on veut à base de légumineuses
pour comparer les valeurs nutritives
nous utilisons une portion de 85 grammes
soit un quart de boîte pour la plupart
des fabricants
quand on regarde la majeure partie des
parts en mille tonnes sur le marché
du côté des films ça va être plus un g 2
g des fois c'est ont un prix du riz brun
et au niveau des protéines ça va plutôt
tourné autour de 5,6 g donc on est à la
moitié d'une table de blé évidemment
quand on veut voir les pâtes à base de
légumineuses
là c'est autre chose c'est comme nos
produits à base de haricots noirs pois
chiches ou lentilles rouges
cette gamme de pâtes offre entre 17 et
37 grammes de protéines un substitut de
viande nous réunissons pascual et fred
pour goûter à des pâtes sans gluten
parmi les plus intéressantes du point de
vue nutritionnel on vous faire goûter un
mythe partent sans gluten que l'on
retrouve facilement sur le marché nous
avons cuit tout les pattes en respectant
scrupuleusement les indications des
fabricants d'abord catelli alors si
blanc riz brun farine de maïs farine de
kinois et mon lycée
au niveau des films on est à 3 g donc ça
ressemble beaucoup à une partie normale
puis au niveau des protéines en acides
gras donc le comme une batterie thème
peu près la moitié de ce qu'on va
retrouver dans son propre but
[Musique]
pour un morceau se rassemblent beaucoup
enquêté lippi baril a apprécié une
question de choix qu'est ce qu'on
préfère comme l'a démontré dans contre
la dengue sont pour elles sont peu trop
de la taxe sur les monnaies le côté de
compliments c'est aussi intéressant
c'est à partir de farine de riz brun
donc le haut niveau des films de
grammont by son petit peu toujours la
même portion 85 grammes et 6 g de
protéines dont vraiment le 3e trois
marques nationales sont assez similaires
ouais ça normal
la texture d'un séparateur du tréfonds
de nos deux invités recherche une pâte
dont le goût et la texture se rapproche
le plus possible des pâtes à la semoule
de blé dur et en accomplissant des
maîtres qui ont des domaines table a
tout donné à tout le monde riches pour
ce set sans gluten
le goût du maïs parce que c'est quand
même prononcé s'est pas mis plus
intéressante au niveau des valeurs
nutritives mais non
la deuxième dégustation est constitué de
produits disponibles surtout dans les
épiceries spécialisées et ils ont une
toute autre apparence je le pense la
farine c'est le policier dans le jeu
la kings soba leur a plu mais pour un
repas asiatique plutôt qu'avec une sauce
tomate
je sache faire sauter une soupe ou et
asiatiques un truc assez fade et ne sait
pas laquelle
c'est à vous une réelle
moi je parle c'est prochain
on ne va rien au moins connu mais non
sera très dense
la pasta joy qui avaient été préparés
selon les instructions il leur a semblé
trop coûteux - qui sont plus ou moins
vraies situe attendre un second temps 5
dans la loire exactement de tous les
produits évalués évidemment la gamme
complète de export cuisine dépasse le
latin armée de l'eau - la teneur en
protéines et en fibres
mais à part ça c'est moche et la paix le
boom convaincre ce serait celle-là que
mon quart besoin ça sera pour passer des
fois faut sacrifier sur la nutrition
vont rendre plus autres sacrifices les
pâtes sans gluten sont difficiles à
réchauffer le land existe des fonds ok
accéder grâce au bout cette fois c'est
juste qu'il faut que ça se fasse
ok tu iras c'est la langue du gluten qui
fait ceux qui parce qu'on répète ce
n'est pas un poison le but est non non
pas du tout on peut en manger
oui sont le cap est donc si on n'a pas
besoin de manger des pâtes sans gluten
pour une question de santé peut-être
qu'il faut revenir à la base des parts
de blé
au final non buteurs ont eu un faible
pour les pâtes catelli barilla et
venezuela c'est à dire alors on peut
dire aux gens ce soit départ dit à nice
ce soir s'en ait raison faut du temps
[Musique]